Congresswoman Angie
Craig speaking out just days
after she was assaulted in her DC
apartment building.
The suspect,
Kendra Hamlin,
is set to face a judge tomorrow
in relation to the attack.
Craig says Hamlin
followed her into her elevator,
asked to use her bathroom
when she refused.
Congresswoman Craig says he bloc
from leaving the elevator
and punched her in the face.
Congresswoman Craig
says she escaped by fighting bac
Luckily,
she had a hot cup of coffee owne
She was able to throw that at hi
And Congresswoman Craig is now O
And Congresswoman, look, this is
you know, just to even hear this
I'm so glad you're okay.
I mean, it's disturbing and terr
Get an elevator.
Something like this happens.
I mean, it's just it's really te
What else can you tell me
about what happened
and when you realized that there
something really wrong?
Well, it was clear from the star
that I was going to have to try
with him in the beginning
to get out of the elevator.
He slipped in
just as my doors were closing.
And, of course,
I tried to stop the progress
of the elevator.
Immediately and
ask him to get out of my elevato
But he insisted
on following me up, wouldn't get
And so look,
at the end of the day,
he jumped
in front of the buttons of the e
asked to go to my apartment,
and there was no way in hell
he was going to get to my apartm
So I had to
to do whatever I could do
to fight my way out of that elev
I mean, that's and I know what h
when you
I'm sure all this happened very
when you look back at it, though
you break it up piece by piece.
I mean, what went through your m
when this was happening?
A block to the elevator buttons?
It's truly terrifying.
And did you even think at the
moment about your coffee
or was that just
sort of instinctual
to use that hot liquid?
Well, I think when he asked to g
my apartment
is when Fight-or-flight
really kicked in for me,
he did jump in front of the butt
At that point,
I tried to move him out of the w
He got behind me
at that point
and I dumped the coffee on him.
You know, at some point
in this scuffle, he he punched m
He sort of
pushed me up against
one of the elevator walls.
And as as the doors opened on th
that we finally arrived at,
he still didn't
want to let me out of the elevat
So I don't know that I had time
quite candidly.
I did what I needed to do
to get out of that elevator.
And I'm really lucky
that he didn't have a weapon.
I suppose now that
I know his arrest history,
I feel
really, really
lucky today
to to be here in Minnesota
talking to you. Absolutely.
And I mean, it is
I mean, one can only imagine
if he had had a weapon,
what could have happened.
The suspect is believed to be ho
And you mentioned his prior reco
I understand
there were 12 prior assaults
on that record.
Some did have a dangerous weapon
So there were times he did have
I know he's
due back in court tomorrow
and he could face up
to ten years behind bars if conv
Congressman, what do you want to
happen here?
Well, number one,
I don't want there to be a 14th
It really is just unbelievable
that I was the 13th assault.
And the reason
we're having a conversation here
and probably the reason that he
he could be held
is because I'm a member of Congr
And this is being
adjudicated in federal court thi
unlike the other 12 instances.
What do I want to see happen?
I want Americans
and especially women to feel saf
in their communities.
And to me,
that means we've got to focus ou
on public
safety, making sure the people w
you know, shouldn't be released
aren't.
But at the same time,
I sit here
and I think to myself,
how did this happen?
12 times in America
with addiction, with homelessnes
with mental health issues,
and this individual
serve ten days, 30 days.
That's no time to be able to get
that this individual needs eithe
So if I can stop there from bein
or 15th or 20th assault
at the same time,
it really does emphasize
the intersection of all of these
we're facing as a country.
Absolutely does.
Now, on
the heels of this,
President Biden called you,
the vice president, called you a
from your state.
Amy Klobuchar, I know, came to s
today, happens to be your birthd
And I mentioned that in the cont
in a few days
you've gone through a terrifying
You've now
got the sort of thinking about l
that a birthday can bring.
You've got the president,
the vice president calling calli
Right.
This has been an unexpected
and awful experience.
But I wonder whether all of this
has changed your view
at all of what you can
and what you want to do in Congr
Well,
I think it it has to change me.
At the end of the day,
I was focused on addiction,
on mental health
as a member of Congress, but
I'm going to be even more focuse
on these issues.
I'm headed to the border
tomorrow, in fact,
with a number of colleagues
to talk about signal
coming into our community
and the addiction challenges we
And at the end of the day, I hop
we can put our heads together
to actually solve the issues of
All of these topics
end up being political wedge
issues in Washington.
Which party can use it against t
to try to divide us?
And I'm not interested
in any of the nonsense they are.
And we've got to make sure
that people are safe in their co
and we've got to make sure
that people can get the mental h
and addiction treatment that the
Congresswoman Craig, thank you v
I appreciate your time and for
sharing all of that with us.
Thank you.